previously on TV since I'm just a guy
standing in front of a boy
I feel the Sun on my face well great get
out the CW checklist cuz you can check
starts with god-awful sappy narration
off the list I swear if an attractive
20-something doesn't even take off their
clothes and this at some point I'll eat
my hat
actually I don't wear hats so Holly your
hat the point is this is so predictable
that I'm in no danger of munching on
that millinery meal it's been 97 years
since a nuclear apocalypse killed
everyone on earth this is a TV show or
an elevator pitch why would you tell me
this instead of showing me 12 nations
had operational space stations at the
time of the bombs there is now only the
arc one station forged from the many the
coincidental existence of all these
inhabitable space stations prior to
Earth's nuclear destruction is
coincidental also do you think when Noah
named his boat he realized he'd be
impacting to still be in fiction for
years to come can't we come up with
something better than the ark also also
how did this work assuming all these
space stations were spread out where did
the vessels come from that took the
engineers to each station and how did
they tow all the space debris back to
the ark what are the chances there would
be enough people qualified to perform
these tasks left alive after the nuclear
fallout and where the did everyone stay
while all these other space stations
were being taken apart since Earth was
not habitable
we're told the earth needs another
hundred years to become survivable again
so 197 year's tone according to
scientists Hiroshima was able to be
occupied within weeks I know that
Chernobyl series has us all worked up
but nuclear plant explosions and atomic
bombs are very different radiation
processes this is reality I'm starting
to think the reality of the CW is that
it has a mandate for chose to go no
longer than a minute without showing
some form of cleavage juvenile offenders
get put here we call it the skybox Jesus
when you have one place for everyone
that is still alive to live there is no
way you have or hopefully you need a
jail taking up this much space unless of
course everyone that survived as a
Philadelphia sports fan and if so then
carry on Clark you are not being
executed you can say to the crowd this
seems like something those angry guards
could have told her if for no other
reason than to make their job a little
easier
also if her mom was this close why
didn't they just wait for her to deliver
the news seems like they could come up
with a catchy name for it like maybe
after earth weight lo 100 smacking you
in the face every Sunday thunderstorm
good welcome back look wells why the
hell are you
here because there's not enough mystery
surrounding wine if they would send kids
to see if earth was a safe habitat or
while these kids were prisoners on the
ark they decided to tease us with some
why does Clark not like Wells intrigue
but I found out they were sending
prisoners to the ground I got myself
arrested I came to you and we could have
a show called the 99 that just doesn't
make sense that was the atmosphere
prisoners of the ark hear me now you've
been given a second chance this whole
thing feels like one of those amusement
park rides where you're strapped in and
then some obviously pre-recorded thing
comes on a monitor two rides position
your experience as if it's happening
only to you now complete with mediocre
acting how is obvious bad boy love
interest guy doing a zero-g ballet when
the ship was literally just shown to be
re-entering the atmosphere not only
would our Earth's gravity be in effect
but the g-forces as the ship went from
orbit speed to landing speed in just a
few minutes would be extremely hot not
now total system failure that's a really
can seeing these two actors together
just made me realize that I want to see
a Battlestar Galactica lost crossover
show instead of this everything that we
programmed in to help them is gone the
crews baffled they've nicknamed it the
advance the plot scenario CW ad libbing
is the [ __ ] best also just realizing
it was really nice that they adults on
the ark to let the kids do their makeup
and hair before being knocked out and
forced on this suicide mission Joey why
a guards uniform I borrowed it to get on
the dropship someone's got to keep an
eye on you
considering the title of the show and
Abigail feeling the need to mention that
there was a hundred of them to Clarke
before she received the sedative I'm
guessing that number is important but in
less than 10 minutes we learned that
Welles was a last-minute addition and
Bellamy is essentially a stowaways so
the leaders of the arc really lucked
into this convenient number that does
have you Blake
Thank You random redshirt for the very
specific and clearly stated exposition
this was actually a Neil Armstrong
second choice of what to say when
stepping on the moon also the CW has
manufactured a plot that results in
attractive young adults being the sole
inhabitants of a new world to be honest
I'm not even mad I'm impressed
how long before the skinny-dipping scene
wow we wouldn't dare play a radioactive
here I will say that the awful
on-the-nose imagined Dragon song is
awful and on the nose this is us if it's
revealed that these two and the cocky
guy are triplets from Pittsburgh I'll
not only give every cent back I'll do
the Mandy Moore pregnant seductive
birthday dance hands off the movies with
us within seconds of landing they've
already got ganks it's like Lord of the
Flies but with none of the intensity
you're compelling storylines that come
when you actually have character
development you need to find Mount
weather
you heard my father's message there has
to be our first priority screw your
father regardless of feelings here
doesn't finding a place where there's
food and shelter make the most sense do
you think we care who's in charge
exactly because the answer is always
Charles we're looking at a 20-mile Trek
okay so if we want to get there before
dark we need to leave now
before dark how about the same day the
average person can walk three miles in
an hour which if this was ideal
conditions it would take them almost
seven hours but these aren't ideal
conditions and they have no food or
water hey space Walker rescue me next
this is totally going to be temptation
Paradise Hotel Island meets lost isn't
it damn it CW why must you torment me I
did something okay something that they
will kill me for when they come down I
can't say what it is just yet but
character has done something that the
audience can't know about yet so they
tell somebody they have a secret but
can't tell them what that secret is even
though in real life they would either
tell them everything or keep it to
themselves cliche we'll be back tomorrow
with food how the - you gonna carry
enough food for us
wells would be great at TV since before
you get any ideas fins line before you
get any ideas I don't care
no from the CW studio execs if you don't
establish a love triangle in the first
15 minutes of the show what are we even
doing here
that's chance that pro tempore you can
give the order to start reducing the
population oh good we're adding some of
that wonderful political intrigue that
made the prequels such a run away
successes
hundreds of innocent people we're gonna
do it by the book is that clear and that
book is The Da Vinci Code seems we have
a traitor in our midst commander hundred
an assassin and there's since two
already died shouldn't Desmond here be
calling them the ninety-eight now or
maybe the 99 since someone snuck on my
point is I want a running tally or I'm
out they couldn't find someone who could
spell die correctly to write the message
or maybe they're gonna actually tie-dye
wells which not gonna lie kind of want
to see take them off the arc will think
you're dead why is that though are you
telling me these fancy medical bracelets
that measure everything from blood sugar
to body temperature can't tell the
difference between being taken off and
the process of dying the body
temperature alone should give it away
just leaving this here is confirmation
that CW pilots are as predictable as the
sunrise man I indeed will not be eating
any hats anyone I think she's dead
because of this manufactured someone's
in peril right before a commercial break
cliche hasn't been paying attention to
the fact that she's already in a love
triangle you can't go off the side of
the triangle until another love triangle
has been established
it's like CW writing 101 what nothing
dragged her around violently for 30
seconds and that's the extent of the
damage note to self
next time save the girl or don't make
lewd comments like that after the girl
was almost eaten by a radioactive sea
serpent I think this is a game
considering the lack of food you could
call it a hunger game a roomful of
scientists and engineers and not one of
them thinks that the kids could be
removing the wristbands look at plasma
osmolarity he's going up across the
board No you've got that backwards an
increase in plasma Osmo
whatever he said would actually mean
dehydration but honestly the sin is
mostly for making me research that is
this implying that sheikah put in the
same cell as her daughter because first
wine and second holy is that a vagina
it's also very convenient that her
daughter just happens to complete this
beautiful drawing on the exact day she
was sent back to earth call that a sip
sip shaming you have to see this you
better come take a look at this cliche
you read anything of that glow in the
dark forest sir man-eating snakes no but
just like the writers of the show I did
see a couple movies called avatar in
anaconda aren't you tired I'm always
doing what's expected of you question I
asked the CW after watching each and
every one of their shows somehow makes
it into the script Jackson
use the wristband there may be a way to
reverse engineer them for communication
talk to Sinclair and engineering wait
what first how is that possible
second why did you wait until now to say
it and third isn't this where the Ninja
Turtles show up and save the day now
this show is setting itself up is
unpredictable at least early on by
coming off one of the main characters in
the first episode surely there won't be
a Thelonious ex machina stop damn it
knew there was a badass in there
somewhere
because risking being eaten by a giant
snake to save Octavia wasn't enough of a
clue we're not alone Jesus this show has
more cliffhangers that are ready Harley
movie you fool now we may never know if
ants can be trained to sort tiny screws
in space to unfasten your seat belt just
push down on the red button on your
right
be sure to gather all your carry-on
items from the under seat compartment
and exit to your left
maybe it's because there are none maybe
we've already been exposed to enough
radiation to kill us sure is pretty
though
and into frame who crawled through a
river and came out clean on the other
side
where are they seats the secret tree
very pure spirits open the door open the
pod bay doors please Hal